for a second day U.S officials
complained that their Reaper drone
crashed into the Black Sea as a result
of what they say has become a pattern of
Reckless and unsafe Behavior by Russian
fighter jerk pilots in international
airspace this time resulting in a
collision I just got off the phone with
my Russian counterpart minister shoigu
Ed as I've said repeatedly it's
important that great Powers be models of
transparency
and communication
in the United States
will continue to fly and to operate
wherever international law allows
this was the first phone call between
the U.S defense secretary and his
Russian counterpart in five months and
it's notable that in the aftermath of
the incident both Moscow and Washington
are emphasizing the need for dialogue
nonetheless Russia disputes the U.S
account of the crash the Kremlin says
the Drone had switched off its
transponder and was heading towards
Russian territory collecting actionable
Military Intelligence against Russian
forces for the Ukraine war effort its
plane scramble to identify the aircraft
and in response the Drone took evasive
action that led to its crash
you have heard representatives of the
Pentagon and the joint Chase of Staff
say the United States will continue to
fly wherever it pleases in accordance
with international law but if you follow
this logic then the space around the
United States has the same status as the
space over the Black Sea
as for the Drone itself Washington says
it's deep underwater and unlikely to be
recovered by the U.S military as far as
uh the loss of anything of sensitive uh
intelligence Etc uh as normal we would
take uh and we did take mitigating
measures uh so we are quite confident
that whatever uh whatever laws of value
is no longer a value Russia says it will
attempt to retrieve the Drone despite
the difficulties whatever actually
happens this incident has heightened the
fear of unintended consequences and the
risk of heightened escalation between
Washington and Moscow
Al Jazeera the Pentagon
Julia Jones from the frontier Europe
initiative she's also a former military
advisor to Nato she says Russia may be
testing the limits of international
airspace rules
if we are looking particularly at the
interjection between the NATO space and
the international airspace we have
before The full-scale Invasion and into
the full-scale invasion a long history
from the Russian side of violation of
NATO airspace in this incident this is
likely to be to have taken place within
the international airspace so what in
the context of the Black Sea the
Russians are likely to be doing is to
try to provoke to determine the
Americans but also NATO overall to not
be able to use international airspace
like they have have tried to determine
NATO forces not to use the international
Maritime space within the Black Sea this
is what they're likely trying to do and
there's another bonus if we can call it
that on the Russian side the mq Reapers
one of the the most advanced and very
expensive
U.S military capability so it's a
significant loss that the Russians the
Kremlin particularly can boast um off in
regards to their domestic public as well
as to the International Community to say
look we are able to down such an
important military capability of the
Americans in international airspace we
do not care about international law this
is these are some of the possible
speculations of why Russia has been
doing this